even good Hollywood movies can be hard
to watch twice in the case of these
films it's not bad writing or uninspired
performances that make the movies hard
to screen a second time rather they're
so depressing
shocking or even terrifying that one
cinematic exposure to them is more than
enough to last a lifetime in the case of
these films they're worth watching but
you probably won't want to see them
again after that requiem for a dream
this adaptation of Hubert Selby --zz
novel is a brutal bleak and a visceral
film in which Darren Aronofsky opens a
window on the lives and experiences of
four different drug addicts and the back
view is decidedly Graham the stunning
visuals and a harrowing story grab hold
of you and don't let go for a hundred
and one excruciating minutes like red
dress in the television it's a mind
bender of a film that will leave you
depressed for days and a seriously
contemplating your own bad habits
Dogville lars von trier's movies all
tend to fit in the category of just one
primus and that's certainly the case
with the second installment of his land
of opportunity trilogy Dogville this
film which is told in nine parts a
chronicles a grueling experience of a
woman who on the run from the Mafia
decides to hide out in a rural town the
residents agreed to provide her shelter
in exchange for her completing their
various low-level chores but her
relationship of the town descends into
unethical abuses of the woman including
multiple sexual assaults all very
difficult to stomach the first time
around let alone on a repeat viewing
passion of the christ' director Mel
Gibson through everything he had into
this harrowing vicious film about the
final days of Jesus Christ as the title
indicates it was meant to be a showcase
of just how much grace and conviction
the religious figure showed in the face
of extreme brutality from his
executioner's and while the film
certainly did its job of reminding its
intended audience of the sacrifices
Jesus endured even viewers who might
have revered his message the first time
may have a hard time bearing witness to
the shocking level of violence again Bad
Lieutenant
on screen sexual violence can be
upsetting in virtually any form but the
sheer luxury of the central character in
Bad Lieutenant is especially difficult
to observe the movie serves to
ultimately exonerate the drug addled
unpredictable officer but
the journey to get to that point teams
with tough material that includes the
assault of a nun and his use of
authority to force two young women into
a sexual act it's impossible to unsee
the events of the movie and hard to
imagine voluntarily watching them again
boys don't cry Hilary Swank's Academy
Award worthy performances brandon teena
a real-life transgender man who was
raped and murdered in 1993 was certainly
groundbreaking as it shed light on an
unexplored sector of hate crimes that
were and are still being committed
against transgender individuals at the
same time it was also incredibly
difficult to bear and probably counts
for many as a movie that's worth
watching once but maybe just the one
time
irreversible this 2002 French horror
film tops many best and worst lists
precisely because of how horrific its
lengthy and gratuitous rapes eNOS the
film tells a reverse chronological story
of a woman who is raped and beaten into
a coma by a notorious criminal and
includes several scenes of intense
cruelty and graphic violence that makes
it almost unwatchable the first time
around for any audience members with
functionalize We Need to Talk About
Kevin as prevalent as mass murder
attacks might be in real life it's still
quite hard to enjoy any piece of artwork
that tries to synthesize the psyche and
history of a young person who commits
these heinous acts in the case of we
need to talk about Kevin and all-star
cast the livers sound impactful work to
peel back the layers of life that led up
to the title character's horrific
actions that said the movie is still
difficult to process and might leave
viewers feeling unfulfilled and even
more hopeless and confuse them before
maybe that's the whole point to
highlight the sheer senselessness of it
all but it's still hard to imagine
working up an appetite to watch it again
precious based on the autobiographical
novel push by Sapphire precious made for
incredible indelible cinema finds the
sand blistering truth about a segment of
society most people might not understand
the movie tells the story of a younger
girl whose life consists of parental
abuse and neglect first poverty second
and who struggled to survive the mean
streets and to even meaner home life is
a daily battle anyone who's seen it no
doubt walked away a little different
than they came in if unwilling to watch
it again
during all seeming here Blue Valentine
derricks en Frances Blue Valentine brims
with roar emotion and sexuality but it's
the depressing nature of the narrative
that really resorts us wanted a dustiest
shelves the film is a categorical
showcase of rich acting by its leads
Michele Williams and wine Gosling but
the biting bitter truth that even the
most earnest romances can sputter out so
spectacularly might hit a little too
close to home for many viewers to push
play again Schindler's List there's no
doubt Schindler's List as one of the
most important films to ever grace a
theater Steven Spielberg's adaptation of
this work of historical fiction that
gave light to the real work Oscar
Schindler did to save the lives of his
Jewish employees during World War two it
painfully depicted the real horrors of
the era in unforgiving detail in fact
it's precisely because of the raw sense
of dread and devastation that it ranks
among those that must be seen at least
once but it's probably difficult to
revisit for most American History X Toni
K's American History X went to some
incredibly disturbing lens to capture
the true depravity that neo nazism
inspires and as fueled by and while the
overarching narrative is optimistic in a
sense that empathy is within reach for
even the most seemingly and salvageable
individuals with a road to that
character recovery is immensely
upsetting to watch not only are the
language and imagery purposefully
offensive but the acts of violence
committed in the movie are unspeakable
it's hard to imagine anyone choosing to
endure it all again after seeing it the
first time thanks for watching click the
loop icon to subscribe to our YouTube
channel plus check out all this cool
stuff we know you'll love to
you